il n'est plus possible de se rendre aux
urgences degré après 21h30 la situation
temporaire inquiète certains habitants
alors que d'autres sont déjà résignés
pas je suis pas rassuré quoi franchement
ouais j'suis pas rassuré du tout on n'a
plus rien à gré de toute façon alors
c'est simple on a déjà pris l'hôpital on
peut pas dire que c'est l'hôpital à on
ya plus l'intervention et en plus on
nous envoie vesoul les urgences par
définition ces urgences donc s'il ya une
bonne raison pour qu'on les écrire donc
les supprimer qu'est ce qu'on fait on va
où résumant son vivant la raison de cet
arrêt le manque de personnel
c'était déjà le cas il ya trois ans
quand le service des urgences avait été
menacé de fermeture durant deux longues
années c'était très très long très très
difficile nous avons réussi à maintenir
les urgences telles qu'elles doivent
fonctionner c'est à dire 24 heures sur
24 et 7 jours sur 7
parce que des urgences qui ne fonctionne
pas de cette manière là ça s'appelle pas
d urgence que s'est ouvert que la jolie
c'est ni plus ni moins qu'à cabinet déjà
deux généralistes décentralisée certains
craignent la fermeture définitive du
service dans les prochains mois mais à
la mairie où la situation est suivie de
près un seul mot d'ordre la confiance
confiance vis-à-vis des autorités de
santé
mais sans oublier de rester vigilant
c'est une situation conjoncturelle ça le
reste c'est une situation exceptionnelle
il est hors de question que les urgences
24 24 ne revienne pas dans les meilleurs
délais un type de fonctionnement pour la
population lilloise mais au delà de la
population lilloise
la direction n'a pas souhaité répondre à
nos sollicitations
dans un communiqué elle indique tout
mettre en oeuvre afin de rétablir un
fonctionnement normal des soins urgents
le plus rapidement possible